welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
vos and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian chapter eight the season
finale titled redemption and the real
redemption of this episode was the one
felt by grown men who spent hundreds of
hours watching Star Wars animated series
because boy oh boy the boiler warning we
now get to use Darksaber in every other
sentence let's actually start with that
burning question and then break down all
the details and Easter eggs that you
might have missed the rest of this
episode and thanks you probably see
about Congress sponsoring this episode
you sign up now at privacy comm slash
new rock stars you can get $5 today to
use on any purchase online for free for
all your holiday shopping ok what is the
dark saber the episode ends with Moff
gideon cutting himself out of its tie
fighter with a black lightsaber now this
is the dark saber and we know it's the
dark saber because there is only one of
them the dark saber is a ceremonial
blade of Mandalore constructed over a
thousand years ago by Tarr vizla the
first a Mandalorian to be inducted into
the Jedi Order every Jedi builds their
own lightsaber to reflect their soul and
tars soul was tarp black when tar died
the Jedi kept the sword in the Jedi
Temple but when the Old Republic fell
the Mandalorian sacked the temple and
took the dark saber back and became the
sigil of the Mandalorian House vizla
generations later during the events of
Clone Wars animated series the
Mandalorian Pre Vizsla led a group of
warriors called the Death Watch to
overthrow Mandalore's pacifist
government he made an alliance with maul
still alive who later executed Pre
Vizsla with the dark saber then moldova
Sidious with the dark sabre it was
awesome Pre Vizsla was voiced by Jon
Favreau showrunner of the Mandalorian
Favreau also played past bhisma in
episode 3 Paz is presumably a descendant
of pre may be his son we aren't sure yet
the dark saber reappeared in Star Wars
rebels discovered by the Mandalorian
highborn Sabine Wren on Dathomir maul's
home world to being later gave the dark
saber to Bo Catan who used it to reunite
to the houses of Mandalore against the
Empire now more on this history as we go
through this episode scene by scene
first there's this hilarious chat
between stormtroopers apparently based
on tag and [ __ ] from the comics now
these stormtroopers are actually cameos
by Jason Sudeikis Adam Paley they burn
time with target practice a nod to the
stereotypically bad aim of stormtroopers
IG 11 returns played once again by Taika
Waititi who directs this episode i g11
is now programmed with nurse protocols
and rescues baby Oda from their
unforgivable child
you pack it all you kidding me
meanwhile Moff gideon whips out his a
web heavy repeating blaster we actually
first saw one of these during the Battle
of Hoth and Empire Strikes Back
Gideon reveals their BIOS I am sure that
Republicans shock trooper Kara Cynthia
dune of Alderaan will advise you that
she has witnessed many of her ranks
vaporized mid descent Kara's homeworld
was Alderaan vaporized by the first
Death Star savage her choice there
gideon explaining why she was so eager
to join this fight gideon also confirms
mandos name Mandalorian hunter din
Jarrah has heard the songs of the siege
of Mandalore
when gunships outfitted with similar
ordinance laid waste to fields of
Mandalorian recruits in the night of a
thousand two huh cool but I'm still
calling mando the siege of Mandalore in
the night of thousand tears are events
that are slated to unfold in the
upcoming season of clone wars in which
Jedi ahsoka tano attempts to free the
planet in the siege but oldest 66 goes
out in the middle of it causes chaos the
Empire ends up taking over boilers I
guess for up history when the kara
appear it's what could happen to him
upload me to a mine flare those are real
that was just wartime propaganda a my
players actually a Dungeons & Dragons
character you may remember it as a name
that they gave to the telepathic monster
and stranger things but maybe it's like
their term for bore gullet remember that
a tentacle lie-detector beast in rogue
one that a force Whitaker might've been
doing weird sex stuff with now we
learned about Moff Gideon to Roth Gideon
no mouth Gideon was executed for war
crimes
Moff Gideon was an ISP officer during
the purge is B stands for Imperial
Security Bureau
meaning Gideon was one of the Emperor's
agents a spy a torturer a watchdog who
sniffed out disloyalty in the ranks the
character Alexander cows from rebels was
actually a nice be officer now the
historical parallel as always with
Empire has been the Nazis so instead of
the night of broken glass we now get the
night of a thousand tears Gideon is
essentially an SS officer who slipped
away from Nuremberg with stolen
artifacts of the people he occupied
instead of Nazi gold it's best scar and
of course the dark saber
we also get some clarification about the
Mandalorian people Mandalorian isn't a
race it's
no you don't have to be born on
Mandalore to be a Mandalorian but you do
have to swear an oath to their warrior
code and like say this is a way after
every fortune cookie mando was rescued
from a separatist attacked by a group of
it turns out Mandalorians and I loved
the electric guitar riff composer Ludvik
göransson scores him with
[Applause]
like who wouldn't want to be a foundling
if this is how cool they sound notice
their blue armor and sigil here this
looks like they could be the Death Watch
which was the warrior group led by
previs Allah in Clone Wars perhaps it
was pre impasses clan who found young
din here well before he continued thanks
to private c-calm for sponsoring this
episode it's still the holiday season
and you're probably using that gift
money to treat yourself with some
holiday shopping online right it's a
season of self giving it's also the
season of accidentally getting ripped
off
that's why privacy can help privacy calm
is a free service where you use a
digital burner card when you shop online
so you don't have to use your real
credit card info and it comes with
limits so subscription services can't
automatically ding you for a month you
don't want happens to all of us right to
privacy cards allow you to control the
limits on them so you can avoid handing
over the keys to your finances every
time you spend money online so for
example I've set up an account with
privacy I've linked my bank account and
I created a card specifically for a
monthly Netflix subscription payment
because now with the Mandalorian item or
the disc I no shame in that for this
virtual card I am setting the limit just
above the monthly subscription amount so
when I commit fully to another streaming
platform and I inevitably forget about
the old ones I've subscribed to they
can't ding me for a second month that I
don't want no vendor can overcharge
beyond the limit you set privacy will
notify you that they blocked it because
the spending limit was already reached
see it is simple it it's fast it's
really just one click they also offer
different plans depending on what you
are and what you need it for like
there's a free plan that lets you create
up to 12 cards a month seems plenty for
someone who's just making a lot of
purchases like I am but also there's a
new pro plan where you can get 36 cards
a month and up to one percent cash back
on purchases if you're a pro but also
there is a team's plan for small
businesses they got you covered whatever
you are just head to privacy comm slash
new rock stars and sign up for an
account that's a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get 5 bucks to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only
yep that's free money folks just go to
privacy accom slash new rockstars to
sign up now so IG 11 speeds into town on
a drive-by with baby Yoda in a kind of
baby Yoda Jorn amazing a flame trooper
arrives to burn them out but baby Oda
repels the fire similar to how kylo Ren
blocks the blaster bolt in the force
awakens Manders helmet is finally lifted
revealing Dan Joran's face and how it
looks a lot like petrol pass cows IG
Florence Nightingale heals them with
back to spray which is the same fluid
from the healing tanks that Luke and
Vader
and thin have used throughout the movies
and they take these sewers to the
Mandalorians covert the armor observes
baby eau de the songs of eons past tell
them battles between man below the grape
and an order of sorceress called Jedi so
the armor is referring to a past
conflict between the Jedi in the
Mandalorians which began the whole
Mandalorian practice of forging armor
from best scar which can repel
lightsaber strikes
maybe we'll see dark super strikes she
orders mando to track down baby Oh to
some rates in season two and gives him
this new signet the skull of a mud horn
which was the beast at mando and baby
otaku defeated and she calls it the clan
of two solidifying their partnership she
also gives them a jetpack he flies now
he flies now the armor crushes in
stormtrooper helmets as the others
escaped down a lava river with an
astromech droid with appendages steering
them singing like a gondolier now there
are definitely some parallels here to
Greek mythology with this river as a
kind of river Styx in the underworld in
the Droid as a Sharon or Charon aka the
ferryman of the River Styx but this crew
can only escape this underworld by
paying the price in this case IG 11 who
sacrifices himself with the
self-destruct function and internal
thermal detonator introduced way back in
Chapter 1 like the t800 who destroys
itself in liquid fire and t2 Judgment
Day this assassin droid turned protector
saves them and helps the cold hero find
his heart but then Gideon swoops in on
his TIE fighter
hey let's make the baby do the magic hat
come on baby
through the magic hand thing
I'm out of ideas but mando brings Gideon
down using a similar lasso maneuver that
he used in its big move in the bar back
in Chapter 1 and grief celebrates the
Varro is a very fine planet and now that
the scum and villainy have been washed
away is very respectable account ya
grief is using the famous description
Ben Kenobi used to describe the Mo's
Eisley spaceport you will never find a
more wretched hive of scum and villainy
as they take off mando allows baby
Odetta gnaw on the mythos or skull
signet of Mandalore that we've talked
about past episodes an informal
induction of this different race into
his Mandalorian Creed which brings us
back to the final shot with jawas
looting the tie wreckage but scared away
by Gideon's dark savour stolen from the
purge along with Mandalorian best scar a
backstory that we may see in the
upcoming Clone Wars season or maybe this
means Gideon killed Bokke tan from
rebels or stole it from Pedro's past
Vizsla the Mandalorian will return for a
second season in fall 2020 when we will
learn more about this mysterious
Excalibur and that dole mysterious child
comment down below with your remaining
lingering questions baby Oda's race and
possible genetic engineering origin who
found finish and in chapter 5 and will
blow that ever crawl out of that Sarlacc
follow me on instagram and twitter at EA
boston subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for joining me
[Music]